Good. Now, let's go to Genesis 18.
>> All right.
>> Okay. Read verses one. Start from what?
I like you. You know I like you because
at least you're honest enough to admit
when you're wrong. And I respect that. I
actually respect you.
>> Huh?
>> Also not, right?
>> That's why I like you. See, now I like
you. Now I can work with you.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Now read start Genesis 18. We're
going to read. It's a long chapter. So
let's read the first 10 verses slowly.
>> Okay.
The Lord appeared to him by the terabs
of Mombay. He was sitting at the
entrance of the tent at the as the day
grew hot. Looking up, he saw three men
standing near him. As soon as he saw
them, he ran from the entrance of the
tent to greet them. And bowing to the
ground, he said, "My lords, if it please
you, do not go on past your servant. Let
a little water be brought. bathe your
feet and recline under the tree and let
me fetch you a morsel of bread that you
may refresh yourselves. Then go on
seeing that you have come your
servants's way. They replied, do as you
have said. Abraham hastened into the
tent to Sarah and said, "Quick, three
seas of choice flour, knead and make
cakes." Then Abraham ran to the herd,
took half took a calf tender in choice,
and gave it to a servant boy who
hastened to prepare it. He took curds
and milk and the calf that had been
prepared, and set these before them. And
he waited on them under the tree as they
ate. They said to him, "Where is your
wife Sarah?" And he replied, "There in
the tent." Now, before you move on, you
notice there it says, "Three men
appeared. They had feet that could be
washed and they ate physical food."
Right?
Reread it again. Look at it. Three men
appeared. He cooked them food. They ate
the food and they had feet to be washed,
right?
>> Uh yeah, sure. Yeah.
>> Say it again.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, good. So, we got that. There are
three men, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, good. So, three men that are
eating food and have feet to be washed.
So, they're appearing in human bodies.
Good. Now, go ahead. It says, "Where is
Sarah?" And he said, "She's in the
tent." Go ahead. Keep reading.
>> I [clears throat] lost my place. I'm
sorry.
>> You were around verse eight.
>> One said to him, "Where is your wife
Sarah?" And he replied, "There in the
tent." Then one said, "I will return you
next year, and your wife Sarah shall
have a son."
>> Okay, now pay attention before you move
on. I want you to know who one of the
speakers is. You're going to now see who
he is. Now this is where you really need
to read carefully. He said, "I will
return next year and Sarah your wife
will conceive and have a son." Right?
>> Yeah.
>> Now keep reading from that point slowly
to see who that speaker is all the way
to verse 19. Slowly.
>> Okay. Sarah was listening at the
entrance of the tent which was behind
him. Now Abraham and Sarah were old,
advanced in years. Sarah had stopped
having the periods of women and Sarah
laughed to herself saying, "Now that I
am withered, am I to have enjoyment with
my husband so old?" Then the Lord said
to Abraham, "Why did Sarah laugh,
saying,
>> Who said Abraham?"
>> The Lord.
>> You sure?
>> Yeah.
>> The Lord, right? Hashem.
>> Okay, good. So, the Lord said to
Abraham, "Keep going.
Shall I in truth bear a child old as I
am? Anything too wondrous for the Lord?
I will return to you at the same reason
at the same season next year. And Sarah
shall have a son. Sarah lied saying, I
did not laugh, for she was frightened.
But he replied, you did laugh.
>> So who replied, "You did laugh."
>> Who replied, "You did laugh."
Uh,
>> when she said, "No, I didn't laugh."
Yes, you did laugh. Who said to her,
"Yes, you did laugh."
You need to reread it again.
>> Yeah, I'm reading it right now. Go
ahead.
>> Why did Sarah laugh saying, "Shall I a
child old as I am? The only thing she
wonders for the Lord, I will return to
you at the same season next year." So,
who's the one saying, "Why did Sarah
laugh and I'll return to you?"
>> It's right there. The Lord said, do you
see it in your verse?
>> Uh, it doesn't say the Lord in my
>> start at 8 again.
>> Uh,
eight.
>> Yeah. Start at verse eight. Mids
sentence. Keep reading slowly so you can
see.
>> He took herds and milk and the calf that
he had prepared and set these for them.
and he waited on them under the tree as
they ate. They said to him, "Where is
your wife Sarah?" And he replied, "There
in the tent." Then one said, "I will
return to you next year, and your wife
Sarah shall have a son." Sarah was
listening at the entrance of the tent,
which was behind him. Now Abraham and
Sarah were old, advanced in years. Sarah
had stopped having the periods of women,
and Sarah laughed to herself, saying,
"Now that I am withered, am I to have
enjoyment with my husband so old?" Then
the Lord said
>> then the Lord said
>> what do you why' you say it doesn't it's
the Lord said what
>> why did Sarah laugh saying shall I in
truth bear a child as old as I am
>> keep the Lord
>> keep breathing
>> I shall return to you the same season
next year and Sarah shall have a son
Sarah lied saying I did not laugh for
she was frightened but he replied you
did laugh
>> who replied
The Lord.
>> Good. We got it. Now continue all the
way to 19. The Lord replied, keep
meaning.
>> The men set out from there and looked
down from towards Sodom. Araham walking
with them to see them all. Now the Lord
had said, "Shall I
>> Who said again?
>> The Lord."
>> Okay, pay attention because I don't want
you to tell me. No, it's not the Lord
speaking. The Lord said, "Shall I do
what with Abraham?" You're going to read
now all the way to 22. Keep reading.
Shall I hide from Abraham what I am
about to do? Since Abraham is to become
a great and populous nation, and all the
nations of the earth are to bless
themselves by him. For I have singled
him out that he may instruct his
children and his cross and his posterity
to keep the way of the Lord by doing
what is right and just, what is just and
right, in order that the Lord may bring
about for Abraham what he has promised
him. Then the Lord said, "The outrage of
Sodom and Gomorrah is so great and their
sin is so great. I will go down and see
whether they have acted altogether
according to the outcry that has reached
me. If not, I will take note." The men
went on from there to Sodom, while
Abraham remained standing before the
Lord.
>> Now, here's where I need you to pay
attention. I want you to reread 20 to 22
slowly, verses 20 to 22 slowly, loudly
to see what the Lord says to Abraham.
He's going to do read it.
The Lord Then the Lord said, "The
outrage of Sodom and Gomorrah is so
great, and their sin so grave, I will go
down to see whether they have acted
altogether according to the outcry that
has reached me. If not, I will take
note."
>> So where is the Lord going to go down?
to Sodom and Gomorra.
>> So the Lord's going to go down to Sodom
and Gomorra, huh?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now read 22.
>> The men went on from there to Sodom
while Abraham remained standing before
the Lord.
>> Okay. So remember when you read earlier
in Genesis 18 verse 1 and 2, it says
three men showed up.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now it says three men showed up
and the Lord just told Abraham, "My next
destination is Sodom. I'm going to go
down there, right?
>> Mhm.
>> But then notice what 22 said. Here's
what I need you because you're going to
really need to pay attention. It says,
"The men headed towards Sodom, but
Abraham remained before the face of the
Lord." Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, if there are three men
and all three of them are only angels
instead of God appearing as a man with
two angels, that means when the men
left, we should expect that three men
would show up in Sodom.
But if one of the three men happens to
be God and Abraham stands before God
who's appearing as a man to continue
talking to him, that means only two men
showed up initially, right? Because
notice in 22 it says the men went but
Abraham remained with the Lord to
continue discussing with him. Right?
You see that?
And 22
You're absolutely silent, so I don't
know what's going on.
>> I'm reading it.
>> Okay, read 22 again.
>> The men went on from there to Sodom,
while Abraham remained standing before
the Lord.
>> And we're going to read the rest of it
where Abraham says, "If there are 50
righteous, will you spare it?" And the
Lord says, "For the sake of 50, I'll
spare it." We'll get there. But what I
want you to see is that it says, "Three
men showed up. If one of those men is
God appearing as a man with two angels,
that means when Abraham remains behind
with the Lord to talk to him and the men
went, that means only two of the three
men ended up in Sodom at first because
the third man remained behind to talk to
Abraham. If I'm right,
right?
>> Uh
>> if I'm right, I'm not saying I'm right.
At the time of the law, can you say that
again?
>> Okay, one more time. You saw in the t
text, three men showed up, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, if one of those three men is God
appearing as a man with two angels, when
God says to Abraham, I'm going to go
down to Sodom, and then it says the men
left, but God remained with Abraham,
that means if one of the three men is
God, but Abraham keeps him occupied in
order to get him to spare Sodom, because
that's the rest of the chapter. That
means only two men left to Sodom
initially because that third man was
detained, right? Because it says Abraham
remained before the presence of the
Lord, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So if I'm right, not saying I am, three
men appear. One of them is God, Hashem
appearing as a man eating food. The
other two are angels accompanying him.
God says to Abraham, which you just
read, I'm going to go down to Sodom. But
then Abraham starts now bargaining with
him. Hold on, God. What if there's 50,
but the other two leave? That means
initially, at first, only two men showed
up at Sodom because the third man
remained behind to talk to Abraham and
then would join them later. Right? If
I'm right?
>> Yeah, sounds about right to me.
>> Okay. Now, read Genesis 19:es 1-3.
Genesis 19:es 1-3.
The two angels arrived in S.
>> How many showed up?
>> Uh two.
>> Where's the third man?
>> Uh he's not there.
>> Where is he?
>> I don't know. It doesn't say.
>> He's in with Abraham in Genesis 18.
>> We're going to get there, but read
Genesis 19:es 1-3 again.
>> Uh the two angels arrived in Sodom in
the evening as Lot was sitting in the
gate of Sodom. Then when Lot saw them,
he rose to greet them. And bowing low
with his face to the ground, he said,
"Please, my lords, turn aside to your
servants house to spend the night and
bathe your feet. Then you may be on your
way early." But they said, "No, I will
spend the night in the square."
>> Okay. Two angels showed up at Sodom and
Lot sees them and he thinks they're men,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, two men show up. But in Genesis 18,
there were three men.
So, where's the third man? Now, let's go
back to Genesis 18, and I want you to
read 22-2 slowly. Go back to Genesis 18
22-2.
The men went on from there to Sodom. A
little louder, brother, so we can hear
it. Speak louder.
The men went on from there to Sodom
while Abraham remained standing before
the Lord. Abraham came forward and said,
"Will you sweep away the innocent along
with the guilty?
What if there should be 50 innocent
within the city? Will you then wipe out
the place and not forgive it for the
sake of the innocent?" 50 who are in it.
Far be it from you to do such a thing,
to bring death upon the innocent, as
well as the guilty, so that innocent and
guilty are alike. Far be it from you.
Shall not the judge of all earth deal
justly.
>> Wait, wait. He's talking to the person
in front of him saying, "You are the
judge of all the earth, and as the judge
of all the earth, you only do what is
just, and far be it from you to destroy
the righteous with the wicked. Won't you
spare the righteous? You see read 25
again one more time.
>> Far be it from be it from you to do such
a thing to bring death upon the innocent
as well as the guilty so that innocent
and guilty far alike.
>> Finish it. 25. You didn't finish verse
25.
>> Thou not the judge of all the earth
justly and the reward answered.
>> Who answered him?
>> Reward.
>> That's verse 26. So read how does he
answer him?
>> Read 26.
>> If I find within the city of Sodom 50
innocent ones, I will forgive the whole
place for their sin.
>> If I find
>> I will go down to Sodom, and if I find
50, I'll spare the whole city. So who's
Abraham talking to?
>> And Abraham says to the Lord, you are
the judge of all the earth.
>> Yeah. And the Lord says, "If I find in
Sodom 50, I'll spare it." Right?
>> Now read 27 to 33 slowly and loudly
because we can't hear you. Sometimes you
start fading. 27-33.
>> Abraham stood up saying, "Here I venture
to speak to my lord. I who am but dust
and ashes. What if the 50 innocent
should lack five? Will you destroy the
whole city or want the pot?"
And he answered, "I will not destroy it
if I find 45 there." But he spoke to him
again and said, "What if 40 should be
found there?" And he answered, "I will
not do it for the sake of the 40."
>> I will not do it.
>> I won't destroy it for the sake of the
40. Only God destroys and saves. But
keep going.
>> And he said, "Let not my Lord be angry
if I go on."
>> Now, are you catching how Abraham's
talking to that person? Let not my Lord
be angry if I keep talking to you.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I want you because I don't want
you to avoid what you just read in your
own Tanakh in your own translation. Keep
reading.
>> Uh and he answered, "I will not do it if
I find 30 there." And he said, "I
venture again to speak to my lord. What
if 20 should be found there?" And he
answered, "I will not destroy it for the
sake of the 20." And he said, "Let not
my lord be angry if I speak but this
last time. What if 10 should be found
there?" And he answered, "I will not
destroy it for the sake of the 10." When
the Lord had finished speaking to
Abraham, he departed and Abraham
returned.
>> Now I want you to read 33.
Slowly and loudly. What did the Lord do?
Verse 33. Slowly and loudly.
>> When the Lord had finished speaking to
Abraham, he departed. And Abraham
returned to his place. There is no way
anyone can tap dance from what we just
read. The Lord finished speaking with
Abraham, departed, and Abraham went his
way. Abraham remained in the presence of
the Lord. Abraham talks to him, "My
Lord, the judge of all the earth. You
will do what is right. There's no way
you can escape that." He's talking to
the Lord God who's there face to face
with him. But in 33, it says, "The Lord
departed. Where was the Lord going to
go?
Sodom and Gomorra.
>> Yes, you got it. How do we know? Read 20
and 21 again. So, we know where the
Lord's going. 20 and 21.
>> Then the Lord said, "The outrage of
Sodom and Gomorrah is so great and their
sin so grave. I will go down to see
whether they have acted altogether
according to the outcry that has reached
me. If not, I will take no.
>> So the Lord tells Abraham, I'm going
down to Sodom. The Lord finished talking
with Abraham and he departs. And in that
conversation, he says, if I find 50 in
Sodom. So God is clearly saying, I'm
going to Sodom and if I find 50 or 45,
I'll spare it. Now go to Genesis 19, the
next chapter. Read 24.
Read 24.
>> The Lord rained upon Sodom and Gomorra
sulfurous fire from the Lord out of
heaven.
>> Wow, you just blew me away. Your Tanakh
written by Hebrew prophets, not
Christians, said the Lord who was on
earth in Sodom brought fire and sulfur
from the Lord out of the heavens. How
many is that?
>> One.
>> No. Reread it again, my friend. I know
you're trying to deny it. The Lord was
on earth and he said, "I'm going to go
to Sodom." He's now at Sodom. But it
says he brought fire from the Lord out
of the heavens. So, you have the Lord in
the heavens and the Lord on earth.
>> Yeah.
>> Say it again.
>> The Lord in heaven and the Lord in
earth.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Good. And the Lord on earth appeared as
a man with two other men. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> There you go, my friend. You're one
close leer to one close. You are one
step closer to the truth.
So your God appeared on earth as a man.
Your God ate food. Your God appeared in
Canaan and spoke to Abraham, then went
down to Sodom and brought fire from
someone else who's God in heaven.
>> Yeah.
>> Beautiful. Now, I'm glad you're honest
because this is where you're going to
come and worship Jesus as your God and
Savior.